foreign
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen that's a camera
wrap on the creator of Iron Man
hi I'm Stan Lee editor of the Marvel
Comics group of superhero comic
magazines
we didn't have any money it was during
the Depression but I would read
everything I could get my hands on and
man I felt as though I could go anywhere
[Music]
what I tried to do was write the kind of
stories I would want to read
our superheroes are the kind of people
that you or I would be if we had a
superpower it's really a religious
Crusade I like to think
Stan was always an upbeat person I never
saw him angry
so many bad s in the world that if you
can entertain somebody for a while it's
a good thing
if you really want to change things and
make them better
you've got to plunge in
foreign
[Music]